we would essentially in the future
become cyborg now that may freak you out
but you can make an argument that today
we're already side Parts let me explain
so if I were to give you a test and I
said you can't use your cell phone and
they already give you the same test and
you could use your cell phone you'd
score significantly higher and so in a
very real way you are smarter with a
cell phone the only difference is that
we have to interface through our fingers
rather than to our minds the reason Elon
is so big on neuralink is so that it
increases our speed of input and
increases our speed of downloading the
information